une tribune à l'initiative du maire de
poissy car la leaf est paru le mercredi
30 décembre signé par 200 élus se
portant volontaire pour se faire
vacciner
le manifeste vise à soutenir la campagne
d'immunisation contre la copie de 19 en
france
l'idée c'est de montrer et toute la
confiance qu'on a dans le vaccin
au delà de des paroles et des échanges
qu'on peut avoir sur les marchés dans la
rue ou quand on est sollicité les
signataires se mobilisent pour
sensibiliser la population autour de la
nécessité de se faire vacciner
c'est le seul moyen selon eux de sortir
de la crise je pense que les élus locaux
les élus nationaux les élus de terrain
doit comme depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire donner l'exemple
on a donné l'exemple sur les masques sur
les gels honda donner d'exemple sur
l'organisation des gestes-barrières
pendant cette crise je pense qu'il faut
aussi donner l'exemple sur cette
incitation se faire vacciner
autres sujets soulevés par les élus la
volonté d'accompagner l'état dans la
campagne dans la mise en place de
dispositifs locaux
nous on est prêts sont calmes et un
gymnase à disposition est prêt je sais
que le président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines métral
vélodrome à disposition il l'a fait pour
organiser les tests ils ont qu'à lever
le petit doigt on se mettra en ordre de
marche et je pense qu'il faut qu'on
accélère les choses il faut qu'on arrête
d'être dans la lenteur et d'attendre
s'il ya des problèmes d'organisation il
faut qu'on sache pour quêter pouvoir
aider des élus locaux qui souhaitent
donc montrer l'exemple à leurs citoyens
et atténuer les doutes autour du vaccin
certains appellent également l'état a
accéléré le processus tout juste mise en
place dans certains états seulement 15
vaccination sont prévues dans les
yvelines pour le moment